- I literally feel like
I'm just eating cold vomit.
(gags and coughs)
(playful music)
- I've tried a little bit of baby food.
I feel like applesauce
is pretty much baby food.
(laughs)
- I've consumed baby food
secondhand, as my baby
vomited it into my mouth.
- Oh my goodness!
- I bought baby food in April,
because I wanted to eat it.
- Most of it grosses
me out, and then I feel
really guilty about giving it to my kids.
Summer Vegetable Delight
is a wonderful name.
- It looks like my cat's vomit.
- Smells like cornbread.
- Is that what you call it?
(sighs)
- Oh my God, that's awful.
- No it's bad.
I think it tastes like dog food.
Is it dog food?
- I taste squash, or
zucchini, or something.
- It tastes like smashed-up peas,
and preservatives, and
maybe there's carrot in it.
- Mnh-Mnh, no, not for me.
- It's super creamy, shiny,
it looks like a banana color.
- The texture and consistency
are very pudding-like.
- It's really sweet.
It's surprisingly sweet.
- Oh my God!
This is terrible.
(laughs)
- I love it.
I would eat this as an adult.
- It's creeping me out
that I'm eating baby food,
but I guess it's good.
- I've never eaten sweet
potato with chicken before,
I don't think.
Is that a weird combo?
- There's some spots.
- I'm wondering if they
put cinnamon or nutmeg
inside of it, or something to spice it up.
- I don't think babies are into spice.
- I don't know what they do to
it, to make it so disgusting.
'Cause just a sweet potato
tastes better than this.
- This tastes like straight-up squash,
and therefore, I don't
want to eat anymore.
'Cause there's chicken in
there, and I can't taste it,
and it's freakin' me out.
- This definitely looks
like traditional baby food.
- It looks like a giant's booger.
- Maybe this is the
reason why kids don't like
green foods, because they're
introduced in this manner.
- Oh God!
- Green beans are already
kind of a soggy vegetable,
- Yeah.
- And this is
just to the extreme.
- My diet this way--
- I am not a fan
of this at all.
- It's not a fan of you either.
- Okay, you can have it.
(laughs)
Gross.
- It was more bland than
I thought it would be.
- Maybe this is the reason why
kids are such picky eaters,
because they're fed such
bland, disgusting foods.
- They're just so tasteless,
but at the same time, disgusting.
It's really confusing.
- Just a tiny bit of hot sauce
in some of those
(laughs)
would make all the
difference in the world.
- He couldn't swallow it.
- I couldn't.
I could not swallow it.
- I didn't eat as much as him. (laughs)
I still have some left.
- I did a big spoonful.